with people recommended to stay home
delivery services have hit peak business
and they are having to adjust
[Applause]
[Music]
and it's not only demand on the rise
responsibilities rising to not only will
have regular inspections of fulfillment
staff and of our careers every morning
now we have special briefings for all
those employees and we underline the
importance of personal hygiene we use
sanitizers for them and so on orders of
electronics clothes toys medicine all
moving online but food deliveries are
perhaps the highest demand right now
it's high from previous weeks no one can
meet such a big demand at once so we
just working on full capacity seven days
a week we continuously bring in more and
more people in deliveries just one of
the options here in Moscow most grocery
stores toy shops or pharmacies still
have their doors open for customers -
and Mondays who come and buy things
offline many are aged simply are not
familiar with online orders and have no
one to help them with it
but Moscow's mayor is advising this stop
over 65s are being urged to stay home
and self isolate themselves for two
weeks a move that is supposed to protect
this vulnerable
did you buy precious silver Osasuna via
I see that I was in
this
and here is the answered Moscow mayor's
office provided a special phone number
for all those who are on self-isolation
and need help so we're gonna call them
and ask how it works you finding how how
they can help so we're gonna wait I
tried one three and two now I just I
don't press anything just wait and it is
in hot line so they're supposed to
answer 24/7 look how it works if the
person who is calling is 65 or over the
Li was a request it could be anything
from going to a shop buying some
medicine or any other vital tasks for
them we make a note of it and then the
request to social services shortly after
on the same day the person is called
back to discuss what where and when the
corona virus pandemic is seriously
testing the country's economies and
medical systems but perhaps the biggest
challenge ahead is a civil one will
people around the globe show a readiness
to support and respect each other during
these toughest of times
you